Let's see who else wants to check in today.
Why don't we go to our caller from the 6:53
area code who's calling today from 6:53?
6:53 we can hear you, we are Urahn.
I'll make one.
I love you.
Yeah.
We're not on speaker, are we?
We're not on speaker.
Oh, man.
That's right.
That's one of the balls.
We're on speaker.
You're not mad anymore.
All right.
What can I do for you today?
I'll make a list.
Interestingly, Kristie, it's really real.
That's what I'm doing.
We kind of gave us a this in my hotel room
on a hotel maid.
This is real.
Right?
I am.
No way.
OK.
Some small ball, the kind of areas in the
world smoke it all up because it's crazy.
Do.
Right.
How do you go?
Good.
How are you?
Gramley, you.
Well, are you talking to me or is there another
conversation happening in the background there?
He said that no matter who you love, are you
high right now?
Yeah, I gotta get going.
Gotcha, gotcha.
All right, well, listen, it's it's really
been a pleasure.
I so appreciate the phone call.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe it actually worked.
It finally happened, OK.
Yeah, man, I love you.
So I'm glad I discovered who you are in your
program.
I think you're awesome.
You are definitely in my daily routine now.
Thank you.
Ever.
I'm Polish.
Crap.
It's over.
You know, I so appreciate the questioning.
Oh, I love your show.
I think you're totally awesome.
Spot on.
I do love it.
And by the way, I was watching your show about
oh, my TV interview answered that we were
with the Trump one where mass murder.
Right.
That was a good segment.
All right, my friend, thank you so much for
the call.
I'm going to let you go.
We are.
At a time and.
Wow.
Today's calls.
I'm sweating, my friends.
I am sweating.
Let's go to a break.
We will take calls again.
Sorry that I was not able to get to everyone
today.